ladies and gentlemen Whitney Houston
during the course of the evening you
have heard the five songs nominated for
original song to refresh your memories I
offered to sing them all again but they
said just read the names so the nominees
for regional song are from poetic
justice again music and lyric by Janet
Jackson James Harris the third and Terry
Lewis from Beethoven's 2nd the day I
fell in love music and lyric by Carole
Bayer Sager James Ingram and cliff
Magnus from Philadelphia Philadelphia
music and lyric by Neil Young
from Philadelphia streets of
Philadelphia music and lyric by Bruce
Springsteen from Sleepless in Seattle a
wink and a smile
music by Marc Shaiman lyric by Ramsay
McLean and the Oscar goes to hmm it goes
to Bruce Springsteen for streets of
Philadelphia from Philadelphia
thank you Jesus is the first song I ever
wrote for a motion picture so I guess
it's all downhill from here yeah but uh
Neil I got to share this with you yeah
you uh you do your best work and you
hope that it pulls out the best in your
audience at some piece of it spills over
into the real world and into people's
everyday lives and it takes the edge off
the fear and allows us to recognize each
other through our fail of differences I
always thought that was one of the
things popular art was supposed to be
about along with the merchandising and
all the other stuff but uh just want to
say thank you Jonathan for having me as
a part of your picture glad my song is
contributed to its ideas and its
acceptance love you Pat's and thank you
all for inviting me to your party
you